[Musik]
Machtkampf in Moskau Gefahr oder
Hoffnung
Donnerstagabend zweites deutsches
Fernsehen es ist 22:14 Uhr und sie sind
mit dabei guten Abend liebe Zuschauer
Russland stammt am Rande des
Bürgerkrieges sagt kein geringerer als
Wladimir Putin viele im Westen und in
der Ukraine halten das für eine gute
Nachricht der söldneraufstand vom
Wochenende könnte der Anfang vom Ende
Putin sein aber angeschlagene Boxer sind
besonders gefährlich und für die
Menschen in der Ukraine wäre das keine
gute Nachricht eine Schwächung Moskau
wünschen sich viele aber eine nuklear
macht die im Chaos versenkt sollte man
vielleicht besser fürchten wir müssen
reden mit diesen Gästen
der Vorsitzende des Auswärtigen
Ausschusses Michael Roth
die Osteuropa Historikerin Franziska
Davis
Kathrin Eigendorf ZDF Korrespondentin
der Politikwissenschaftler Johannes
Fahrweg
Frank sauer Sicherheitsexperte
und der langjährige US-General hot chest
sie sind zu Gast bei Maybrit
Illner und die begrüßt alle Gäste der
Sendung nochmal sehr herzlich los geht's
Meuterei Umsturz oder Protestmarsch was
war das da am Wochenende in Russland
wer ist Koch wer Kellner und werde jetzt
noch Vorkoster für Putin sein
[Musik]
der Kreml-Chef macht aus einer riesen
Blamage eine Heldentat
unsere Waffenbrüder starben bei der
Konfrontation mit den Rebellen
sind wir im falschen Film von der
russischen Armee sah man nichts am
Wochenende
nur Wagner Söldner 200 km vor Moskau
und jetzt gehen die prigoshi vor
begeisterten Groupies in der Rose zero
in Rostock am Don
[Musik]
i diejenigen die diesen Aufstand
vorbereitet und organisiert haben haben
Russland verraten und werden bestraft
wieder Filmriss Verräter prigosin jettet
ungestraft nach Minsk und die 25.000
Wagner Söldner
ihr könnt einen Vertrag mit dem
Verteidigungsministerium unterschreiben
oder zu euren Familien zurückkehren oder
wer es möchte kann nach Belarus gehen
ja ist das jetzt eine neue Diktatur
aller Kart
Putin der kleinen bei gibt weil größere
Gefahren lauern
der russische general Sergej sorovicin
soll in den wagneraufstand verwickelt
sein er wird festgehalten und wurde vom
Staatsanwalt befragt zu seinen
Verbindungen zu
Trigger
[Musik]
es gibt viel zu verstehen Katrin
Eigendorf ist bei uns
zdf-off also von dem Oberbefehlshaber in
der Ukraine
also es deutet einiges darauf hin dass
Putin da eine Säuberungswelle vornehmen
könnte das ist natürlich im Moment
bewegt jetzt alles sehr auf spekulativen
Gebiet aber dass er auf einmal
festgenommen ist und von der Bildfläche
verschwunden ist
ja es hatten einige ja auch erwartet
denn ohne Konsequenzen kann die
Situation nicht bleiben und das
hier nicht alleine gehandelt hat sondern
in der Elite und auch in der
militärischen Elite des Landes eine
Unterstützung hat davon musste man
ausgehen sonst hätte er sag mal die
Situation nicht in dieser Form eskaliert
also das ist sicherlich
ein Krimineller und Kriegsverbrecher
aber er ist nicht völlig dumm also der
hat schon an Macht Umstürzen in ganz
anderen System mitgewirkt also der wird
eine Strategie haben und wie gesagt ich
schließe mich dieser Spekulation an ich
halte das für wahrscheinlich dass
wir da jetzt in nächster Zeit einige
Säuberungen erleben werden nun ist
prigoshine ja nach einem Tag
zurückgetreten von diesem Putsch oder
von diesem Aufstand muss man sagen Frank
sauer ist bei uns
Militärexperte Politikwissenschaftler
aus München von der Bundeswehr Uni
können wir verstehen kann man schon eine
Ahnung warum was eigentlich der Grund
war sich zurückzuziehen man hat erstmal
gemerkt dass da auf einer Autobahn eine
Kolonne offensichtlich vorwärts kommen
konnte und weit vorwärts kommen konnte
bis kurz vor Moskau und so gut wie nicht
angegriffen wurde also man hat sich über
beide Seiten gewundert über den Abbruch
als auch über das nicht angegriffen
greifen diese Armee
ja in der Tat es war schon stellenweise
geradezu bizar mit Blick auf ihre Frage
warum dieser plötzlich sozusagen dieses
plötzliche Ende dieses Unterfangens da
würde ich sagen halb zogen sie ihn halb
sank er hin also meine Vermutung ist
dass er natürlich schon gemerkt hat dass
wenngleich ist aber vermutlich
Absprachen gegeben haben muss im Vorfeld
sich da niemand dezidiert auf seine
Seite gestellt hat auf Seite auf
putinseite hat sich übrigens auch
niemand gestellt es ist ja nicht so dass
der Sicherheitsapparat irgendwie
funktioniert hätte
Gouverneure mussten sozusagen die
autobahnaufbaggern lassen in dieser in
der Hoffnung diesen konvo irgendwie
aufzuhalten aber Pilotin muss wohl 200
km vom Moskau bemerkt haben niemand
steht auf meiner Seite und dann muss es
möglicherweise Telefonate gegeben haben
in denen ihm einen Deal vorgeschlagen
wurde ob wir das je erfahren würde was
da gesprochen werden
was da gesprochen wurde weiß ich nicht
aber
ich würde vielleicht auch ein bisschen
auch mal an da immer zu viel rein zu
Geheimnissen das sah ziemlich chaotisch
aus und ich glaube genau das war es auch
es war chaotisch und es war ungeplant
obwohl es von Seiten pregorians
einigermaßen geplant Schienen denn er
schien ja darauf vorbereitet zu sein das
ja also es wurde ja so getan als wäre
der unmittelbare Auslöser der Beschuss
gewesen dieses wagnercamps in der
Ukraine mit Raketen angeblich angeblich
von Seiten der russischen Streitkräfte
sollte stattgefunden hat wissen wir
nicht aber was definitiv ausgeschlossen
werden kann ist das nach diesem
Beschluss innerhalb von weniger Stunden
ich also tausende Mann zusammenziehen
kann mit militärischem Gerät und einen
solchen Konto in Gang setzen das heißt
der war geplant und das behaupten ja
inzwischen auch die Geheimdienste aber
das Ziel war ja offensichtlich gewesen
also den verteilungsminister und den
generalstoffchef in Rostock Anton im
Prinzip auch zu stellen und das scheint
wohl private deswegen nicht gelungen zu
sein weil durchgesickert war das alles
vor hat und deswegen musste so kann man
es lesen seine Pläne vorziehen und das
hat unter Umständen auch dazu geführt
dass es dann am Ende ja in diese in
diesen seltsamen Putsch aus Versehen
quasi übergegangen ist weil er hat am
Ende dann nachdem Putin ihn ja zum
Verräter deklariert hat tatsächlich
gesagt er fährt jetzt nach Moskau und es
wird demnächst einen neuen russischen
Präsidenten geben das heißt von Meuterei
hat sich das Ganze aus versehen
wir sind dankbar dass Franziska Davis
bei uns ist Osteuropa Historikerin auch
in München an der maximilian-universität
Frau Davis gibt es immer noch Menschen
die glauben dass dieser Putsch diese
Meuterei dieses Aufbegehren eine
Inszenierung sein könnte ich frage mit
dem Hintergrund dass rigos im Grunde der
einzige war der sowohl den
Verteidigungsminister als auch gerade
dass sie noch so öffentlich kritisieren
durfte und im Grunde genommen auch Putin
so kritisiert hat wie kein anderer und
man dachte ja immer dass der das machen
darf und vielleicht auch machen soll
weil es Putin irgendwas nutzt also
könnte auch dieses ein Teil einer
Inszenierung sein nein das halte ich für
ausgeschlossen also es gibt einfach
keine Hinweise darauf und ich glaube
dahinter steht das Missverständnis was
sehr lange auch dass der die deutsche
Wahrnehmung von Putins Russland oder von
Putin persönlich auch geprägt hat dass
er irgendwie dieser Master meint ist der
ganz genial irgendwie da seine Pupp
Pflanzen lässt und das ist er nicht also
ich glaube man muss sich das Ganze eher
wirklich als ja ein eher also die
Analogie von einem von einer
Mafia-Organisation passt da glaube ich
eher also unterschiedliche
verbrecherische gewaltbereite Typen mit
Putin natürlich an der Spitze das ist
klar aber die in einem komplexen
loyalitätsverhältnis zueinander stehen
mit qualitätsgeflechten die wir auch gar
nicht so durchschauen also ich glaube da
wird das schließlich mich den Vorrednern
Vorrednerin absolut an ja also das wird
noch ich als Historikerin sage es dauert
noch Jahrzehnte mindestens bis wir da
genauere Informationen haben dass wir da
die Quellen haben aber ich glaube gar
nicht dass wir so viel Neues über das
System Putin gelernt haben weil das ist
eben dieses dieses Geflecht ist dass
nicht auf starken Institutionen beruht
sondern das auf beruht auf diesen
personellen loyalitätsstrukturen und das
die natürlich außer ähm aus der Reihe
geraten können gerade wenn so ein System
unter Druck gerät und das ist natürlich
der Fall die Offensive also der Krieg
gegen die Ukraine läuft nicht so
eingeplant das ist nicht nach drei Tagen
vorbei gewesen die wir alle wissen und
insofern würde ich schon auch denjenigen
zustimmen die sagen man sieht hier Risse
man sieht hier ein Autoritätsverlust und
putin war so muss man sagen dumm genug
selber die 1917 als Referenz zu nehmen
obwohl die eigentlich gar nicht so passt
aber ja immerhin als dann das ganze
System zusammengebrochen ist in seiner
ersten Rede in seiner ersten Rede aber
es war einfach nicht dumm diese
Assoziation zu wecken aber so ein Ende
kann sich natürlich lange hinziehen also
das heißt jetzt nicht ich recht also
solche Systeme können viel schneller
kollabieren als wir denken die sind
weniger stabil als sie scheinen als auch
dieses stabilitätsargument dass uns so
lange vorgehalten wurde warum Putin
angeblich sozusagen das kleinere Übel
sein ich glaube das hat sich jetzt in
aller Deutlichkeit gezeigt dass das sehr
schnell kollabieren kann aber eben nicht
muss ein ein Ende das ist inkludieren
das weiß man auch historisch eines
Herrschaftssystem kann sich lange
hinziehen und wir haben ja auch gesehen
dass und das ist glaube ich wirklich das
entscheidende und was wichtiger ist als
solche Spekulation über jetzt wer da
jetzt mit wem wo wir so wenig
Informationen haben hier wurde weiter
bombardiert ja also die dieser Krieg
gegen die Ukraine der ist weiter
gegangen und auch sie haben am Anfang
gesagt die Ukraine nehmen das schon
natürlich sie hoffen auf einen eine
Schwächung des Systems damit hoffentlich
dass eine Auswirkung hat auf die
Offensive gleichzeitig ist sehr wohl
wahrgenommen worden naja es ist wer ist
der Mann der hier als Gegenmodell
plötzlich auftritt das sind zwei
Verbrecher die beide das ist klar im
Kriegsverbrechen und insofern ist es
auch sind also in der Ukraine so zwei
Menschen die sich darüber streiten wie
man effizientesten
Definition oder ihr ihre These darauf
wer diese pregorien nun eigentlich ist
und was sein Ziel war würden Sie sagen
er ist in aller erster Linie Patriot der
Russland retten wollte oder ist er
Geschäftsmann nein er ist
gewaltunternehmer er ist
gewaltunternehmer er ist eine SMS jemand
der groß geworden ist durch Putin also
Essen sozusagen Putins Kreatur der
gleich geworden ist Putin der sein
Netzwerk sehr stark auf also eigentlich
Putin verdankt seine Macht Putin
verdankt die Verträge in Afrika in
Syrien also dass sie dort auch dort wo
sie überall Kriegsverbrechen schlimme
Kriegsverbrechen begangen haben und
weiter begehen übrigens das hat er alles
Putin zu verdanken und er ist ein
Beispiel das Putin eben die eigenen
geschaffenen Kreaturen eben nicht in der
Hand hat in der Hand hat aber das ist
sozusagen der Kern des Systems
Michael Roth ist bei uns
Vorstandsvorsitzender Quatsch
Vorsitzender Vorstandsvorsitzender
Auswärtigen Ausschusses
sie sind sehr rot natürlich genauso
überrascht gewesen oder nicht überrascht
gewesen wie wir das die Bundesregierung
keine Information durch den BND hatte
und offensichtlich auch die Amerikaner
nicht für nötig befanden den BND zu
informieren damit der BND die
Bundesregierung informieren kann
ach Frau ellner sind gleich zwei Fragen
in einer ein großes Stöhnen Helmut
Schmidt wird ja zugeschrieben
er soll mal gesagt haben
wenn man
Qualitätszeitungen jeden Tag aufmerksam
studiert weiß man bisweilen mehr als die
Berichte aus der Nachrichtendiensten ich
lasse das jetzt einfach mal so
hingestellt sein das weiß ich nicht ich
bin aber erstmal froh dass der
Bundeskanzler ja auch schon gesagt hat
Leute es gibt hier Gesprächsbedarf denn
ich will nicht behaupten dass ich
gewusst habe das ist auf so etwas
hinausläuft aber was ich mich seit
Wochen Frage und ich will jetzt nicht
zynisch sein wie kann man in einer
Diktatur dann doch über Freiheitsrechte
genießen denn Herr prigorchin war ja
einer der offen die Macht Elite
kritisieren konnte auf übelste Art und
Weise und ich habe mich immer gefragt
wie lange kann ihm das eigentlich Putin
noch durchgehen lassen denn diese Narren
Freiheit dafür muss es ja Gründe geben
und darauf habe ich keine Antworten
gefunden jedenfalls nicht nach
Rücksprache mit Menschen die sich damit
offenkundigt tagtäglich beschäftigen
sondern wir sind dankbar für gut
informierte Journalisten die das auch in
dieser Sendung schon erzählt haben
vermutet haben und zur Kenntnis haben
wir sind genauso dankbar heute in
unserer Sendung Professor Farwick
begrüßen zu dürfen von der Universität
Halle fertig was würden Sie sagen
überspricht jetzt natürlich die halbe
Welt viele haben eben den Daumen
gedrückt
sie auch
nein ich fand die Reaktionen in der
deutschen Öffentlichkeit ziemlich
befremdlich es gab ja so zwei Lager die
das eine Lager sagte je mehr Chaos in
Russland herrscht desto besser ist das
für die Ukraine weil dann Russland die
Aggressionen nicht mehr fortsetzen kann
und das andere Lager und zudem habe ich
mich gezählt
hat mit Sorge auf diese Entwicklung gebt
und
Instabilität gefürchtet in der Erwartung
dass nach Putin nicht besseres kommt die
Vorstellung des gewissermaßen ein
Piroggen Präsident werden kann es
sowieso absurd aber das aus sozusagen
aus dieser Gemenge Lage in einer solchen
Situation wie in Russland eine sozusagen
bessere Gestalt hervorgeht die dann für
uns besser ist und auch für die Ukraine
besser als die habe ich nie gehabt
insofern hatte ich Sorge und ich glaube
viele haben unruhig geschlafen ich würde
aber auch sagen dass man überhaupt
nicht überbewerten soll ich meine diese
These dass er 200 km vor Moskau
die ist schon relativ kühl ich glaube
nicht dass es realistisch gewesen wäre
dass man den Machtapparat Putins damit
in Gefahr hätte bringen können das
einzige Kalkül was Sinn macht und wir
wissen es nicht aber das einzige was
Sinn macht wäre doch gewesen dass er auf
dem Weg dahin gewissermaßen Zulauf von
relevanten Kräften gefunden hätte und
dann eine Dynamik entstanden werden wo
das hätte Erfolg haben können aber das
war eigentlich nicht zu erwarten
insofern soll man das auch nicht
überhöhen und am Ende ist es so dass
Putin dieser kalte macht Politiker
dieses Ding gewissermaßen jetzt
sicher nach Hause geschaukelt hat das
ist nicht so dass jetzt ähm damit alle
Probleme gelöst sind für ihn und
natürlich hat das Risse offenbart in dem
Machtapparat aber für den Moment
gewissermaßen hat Putin diesen
Machtkampf gewonnen das heißt also die
Hoffnung dass Putin weg ist und dann
daraus ein Ende des Kriege Krieges
resultiert oder gar ein Nachfolger
einfacher für uns und die Ukraine ist
die soll man glaube ich nicht haben wenn
ich runter machen man muss mit dem
Russland umgehen wie es ist und wir
sollten uns darauf einstellen das Putin
erstmal der ist der sozusagen da als
Verhandlungspartner in Frage kommen muss
erstmal rausgehalten erot wieder Worte
ich teile das was er war wie gesagt hat
so gar nicht niemand hat gewonnen und
erst recht nicht Herr Putin Herr Putin
stand als Kaiser einen Moment nackt da
und wir müssen uns nur einen Moment in
eine Diktatur hineinversetzen eine
Diktatur lebt ja davon dass es einen
gibt der schalten und walten kann der
alles unter Kontrolle hat und es gab
einen absoluten Kontrollverlust das ist
für einen Diktator ein Super-GAU und wir
müssen noch mal ein bisschen in die
jüngere Geschichte Russlands gehen
Putin hat ja wenige Versprechungen
halten können gegenüber seiner eigenen
Bevölkerung aber er hat zumindestens für
eines stets gesorgt im Inneren herrschen
Ordnung und Sicherheit und das ist ein
für die russische Bevölkerung ganz ganz
wichtiges Element weil die alle noch die
chaotischen 90er Jahre unterhält ziehen
in der Erinnerung haben die ihn viel
Angst und viele Sorgen bereitet hat und
egal was passiert ist Armut soziale
Ungleichheit aber Sicherheit und Wohnung
konnte Putin versprechen und jetzt ist
vor den Augen der Weltöffentlichkeit
auch von den Augen der russischen
Bevölkerung dieses große putinische
Versprechen brüchig geworden und das
kann man nicht so einfach aus dem Weg
räumen und deswegen befürchte ich jetzt
auch schlimme Konsequenzen er wird die
stalinisierung im Inneren fortsetzen und
er wird sicherlich in unverminderter
Härte jetzt auch auf die Ukraine
einschlagen weil er braucht jetzt ja
Erfolge um deutlich zu machen ich bin
wieder da und insofern ist das
tatsächlich auch ein
zwiegespalten weil man auf der einen
Seite sieht das Putin angegriffen wird
und zwar im Inneren angegriffen wird
aber die Frau David sagte von anderen
Kriegsverbrechern also ich weiß jetzt
nicht wer sich gefreut hat also ich
kenne diese diese diese diese Einteilung
von den Barbie die kenne ich jetzt nicht
ähm niemand hat sich gefreut hat
mir eine besorgt aber ich habe mich auch
gefragt wie wie kann man in einem so
hochgerüsteten Land immerhin 200 km an
Moskau heran drücken und pregorian ist
es ja offenkundig gelungen sechs
Hubschrauber und ein Flugzeug
abzuschießen das ist mehr als die
ukrainischen Truppen in zwei Wochen
erreicht haben also die also da scheint
es schon eine große Effektivität bei den
brigon bregorianischen Truppen gegeben
zu haben die immer hatten die sie immer
hatten selbstverständlich gekämpft die
haben lange und brutals möglich insofern
will ich Ihnen natürlich auch recht
geben
ist nicht der gute in diesem Spiel ganz
im Gegenteil er ist ein Monster von
Putins Gnaden er ist genährt und groß
und reich und mächtig gemacht worden ja
und dann kam es eben zu dieser
Auseinandersetzung es geht ja nicht nur
um Russland und die Ukraine ich meine
die Wagner Truppen haben überall die
Finger mit dem Spiel und das hat ja auch
vor David schon angedeutet Afrika
Syrien und wir wissen nicht was da
eigentlich passiert nur wenn man jetzt
den stallinismus sieht befürchte ich
jetzt wieder nicht klingen die
Lebenszeit von prägossen könnte begrenzt
sein weil man in Russland üblicherweise
solche Probleme mit Gift oder mit
anderen Mitteln die tödlich verlaufen
löst man sollte noch mal die Frage
stellen welches Ziel also prigosh ihn
eigentlich hatte er tatsächlich das Ziel
schon gut und gerassimov zu stellen oder
zu eliminieren wie man in Russland ja
gerne formuliert oder ging es ihm darum
seine Privatarmee und seine eigene
Position zu retten denn es gibt ja den
Plan die gesamten Privatarmeen in
Russland zu integrieren in das russische
her
beides bevor ich dazu kommen noch
Einsatz zu Herrn Warwick weil
strategisch betrachtet gibt ja auch die
Ableitung auch keinen Sinn also es ist
ja völlig müßig dass wir uns hier
sozusagen irgendwie in sorgen wälzen ob
vielleicht nachher Putin noch was
schlimmeres kommt die haben ohnehin
keinen Einfluss darauf der einzig
vernünftige Schritt den wir machen
können ist möglichst klug und Szenarien
über zu überlegen wie wir damit umgehen
sollte so etwas passieren und der Rest
sagen ist aus meiner Sicht sinnloses
führen von sorgen die niemanden was
nutzen dazu und was sie sagten ja
natürlich also ich hatte das vorhin ja
schon mal ganz kurz skizziert so wie man
das deuten kann was wir wissen waren
scheuge und gerassimov beide von
pigologin sehr verhasst insbesondere
Scheu weil er ihn eben für rasend
inkompetent hält Putin hält aber an ihm
fest nicht weil er ihn für kompetenter
hält sondern weil er loyal ist also Frau
david hat genau den Nagel auf den Kopf
getroffen in der Hinsicht das heißt
eigentlich müsste Putin die beiden
längst entlassen haben und das kann ja
schon jetzt dann erst recht nicht mehr
tun weil dann würde er diesen alles gibt
rechtfert genau wenn das Gewinner gibt
sind folgen noch am meisten ja weil die
ist sozusagen geschafft haben sich
dadurch zu laborieren und jetzt
natürlich noch mehr an Putin sozusagen
gebunden sind aber wie gesagt ich hatte
das gesagt ich glaube privat war selber
davon überrascht dass er am Ende dann
sozusagen Richtung Moskau fahren musste
und möglicherweise hat ihn da auch
sozusagen sein eigener Mut verlassen
deswegen er
den Exit ja die Abfahrt dann genommen
hat die ihm die man im Angeboten man
muss noch mal die besondere Rolle von
Weißrussland verstehen und vom Präsident
Lukaschenko und wir schalten deshalb
nach Frankfurt jetzt zum ehemaligen
Oberbefehlshaber des us-heeres in Europa
Ben Hodges ist in Frankfurt für uns
heute Abend guten Abend die erste Frage
gleich in ihre Richtung
Lukaschenko soll das vermittelt haben
wenn heute ist es vorstellbar in ihren
Augen diese Vermittlerrolle des
Bella russischen Präsidenten
Präsident Lukaschenko tatsächlich der
Gewinner dieser gesamten Situation ist
denn jetzt hat er potenziell diese
starke Persönlichkeit nämlich pregorian
unter seiner Kontrolle wenigstens aber
in seinem Land potentiell dazu noch
mehrere tausend Wagner Söldner und das
verleiht ihm eine Rolle bzw eine
Position auch russischen Versuchungen zu
widerstehen eventuell Teile von Belarus
zu übernehmen und dort Widerstand zu
lassen es gibt ihm dann auch noch einige
Stärke gegen seine eigenen Opposition
die Sicherheitskräfte in Polen und in
Litauen sind im Augenblick stark besorgt
weil sie glauben dass Belarus auch
Migranten nutzen könnte um Druck auf die
Grenzen dieser Länder auszuüben und
damit auch auf die Grenzen der
Europäischen Union das ist also jetzt
eine ganz andere Dynamik und dadurch
hatte im Lukaschenko eine ziemlich
starke Position was werden die
wagnersoldaten in Belarus machen glauben
sie von wem werden die da bezahlt was
werden ihre Operationen sein
die wagnergruppe ist eine global
operierende internationale Organisation
ich glaube nicht dass ihre Operationen
in den afrikanischen Ländern Osten jetzt
deswegen aufhören werden und ich kann
mir auch nicht vorstellen dass die Zahl
der Wagener Söldner die in Belarus sein
werden wirklich die gesamte Stärke der
Truppe da umfasst wir wissen noch nicht
einmal genau wie viele dann Mitglieder
sind und ich kann mir nicht vorstellen
dass Herr prägutschein für den Rest
seines Lebens in Belarus bleiben wird
wenn ihr dort bleibt dann kann ich mir
nicht und vorstellen dass er noch
besonders lange leben wird aber ich kann
mir durchaus vorstellen dass wir los
vielleicht eine Basis für ihn und seinen
Operationen in anderen Ländern wird und
währenddessen werden die Wagener
Soldaten natürlich hier mit einer
besseren Option oft tatsächlich versorgt
wenn es darum geht dass sie da in Villa
Russland bleiben können statt in die
russischen Streitkräfte eingegliedert zu
werden da haben sie jetzt ganz ihre
Privilegien wahrscheinlich eine bessere
Bezahlung und auch eine geringere
Möglichkeit getötet werden und genau das
wären die nächste Frage gewesen ob und
wie viele Wagner Soldaten diese
Integrierung in das russische Heer
machen würden weil sie es attraktiv
finden sie finden es natürlich überhaupt
nicht attraktiv sondern würden sich eher
in Richtung Belarus bewegen wie wird aus
amerikanischer Sicht das gewertet was da
am Wochenende geschehen ist welchen Reim
macht sich die US-Administration darauf
President ich glaube dass unser
Präsident und unsere Regierung wohl die
meisten Sorgen
hatten dass es einen raschen
Zusammenbruch der Regierungsstrukturen
hätten geben können und dass die
Kontrolle über die nuklearen
Waffenarsenale verloren hätten gegen
können und ich glaube diese Sorge gab es
wohl auch in China aber ich denke dass
wir trotzdem noch überreagieren wenn es
auch nun diese theoretische Möglichkeit
gibt wir haben jetzt schon gehört welche
Bedingungen gegen Ende der Sowjetunion
geherrscht haben unter den unter der
Herrschaften borisiert sind für mehrere
Jahre herrscht dort ein gewisses Chaos
in den Straßen und Oligarchen haben die
Kontrolle und auch die Finanzwelt dort
übernommen aber es gab eigentlich nie
die ernsthafte Frage was mit den
Nuklearwaffen passieren würden die sind
immer in den Händen und der
Verantwortung der verantwortlichen
Behörden gewesen auch während der Zeit
dieses fast Zusammenbruches aber die
Vorstellung dass das Putin Richie März
zusammenbrechen würde und das ist dann
eben Nuklearwaffen überall in Russland
verteilt
das ist etwas was wahrscheinlich ähnlich
dem sein würde wie gegen Ende der
Sowjetunion das nämlich diese
Nuklearwaffen in aller
Wahrscheinlichkeiten nach wie vor ihm da
unter der Kontrolle verantwortlicher
Behörden bleiben würden und das ist
etwas worauf wir uns natürlich auch
gedanklich vorbereiten müssen das ist
interessant dass Sie das sagen weil wir
sie in Erinnerung behalten haben mit dem
Gedanken vor diesen Drohungen Putins
eben nie zu viel Respekt oder zu viel
Angst zu haben wenn Russland auseinander
viele dann bestünde diese Gefahren
natürlich auf jeden Fall ist es wichtig
sie zu wegen und dann wünscht man sich
auf der einen Seite also das Putin ginge
aber das Russland nicht
auseinanderfallen darf ist das richtig
im Kopf behalten und ich weiß dass wir
auch hier eine geschichtsprofession am
Tisch ansetzen haben das Russland in den
letzten fünf Jahrhunderten immer ein
reich gewesen ist nie ein Nationalstaat
wie Deutschland die Vereinigten Staaten
oder Frankreich ist immer ein reich
gewesen ein Imperium und deswegen hat
das russische Volk sich nie mit den
Konsequenzen dessen auseinandersetzen
müssen ja die einfach aus dem
schrecklichen Entscheidungen ihrer
führungspolitiker und ihre Führungsriege
hervorgekommen sind und wenn wir jetzt
keine Veränderung sehen nach diesen
Jahrhunderten eines imperialen Reiches
und dann wird es nach Putin
wahrscheinlich jemanden geben der
ähnlich ist es sich schwer vorzustellen
dass er schlimmer sein wird aber es gibt
da dann eben natürlich das die
militärische Strukturen und es wird
weiterhin eine schrecklicher Ort bleiben
es wird wahrscheinlich ja schlimmer
werden aber es wird immer eine Putin
ähnliche Person sein und dieses Regime
wenn diese Regierung endlich
zusammenbricht dann gibt es vielleicht
auch die Möglichkeit dass etwas anderes
entsteht und dass da die Russinnen und
Rosen auch ihre eigenen Problemen lösen
können statt immer nur die Gewalt zu
exportieren wie sie das in den
vergangenen fünf Jahrhunderten getan
haben wir melden sich am Tisch gleich
zwei nämlich alle und wir fangen
vielleicht mal an mit seinen sauer ich
gebe general Hotels natürlich vollkommen
Recht Instabilität in einem nuklearstaat
ist keine schöne Vorstellung ja aber mit
Blick auf die auf das Wochenende kann
ich schon glaube ich ein bisschen
Kontext liefern und ein bisschen besser
sozusagen ein Risiko Abwägung erlauben
den Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauern weil
man darf sich das auch nicht zu einfach
vorstellen es ist tatsächlich eigentlich
auch vieles in Anführungszeichen besser
geworden im Vergleich zum Zusammenbruch
der Sowjetunion in den 90er Jahren das
hat auch was mit
reduction Programm zusammen also zu tun
also Programm die gemacht wurden
zwischen Russland und den USA
um die Sicherheit der Atomwaffen zu
erhöhen so das heißt jetzt sage ich mal
ganz konkret ungefähr auf halbem Wege
zwischen Roste von dort und Moskau liegt
und woran es 45 ist eine
Militäreinrichtung von der Autobahn noch
mal 150 km entfernt Richtung Osten die
eine ist von 12 nationalen Lagerstätten
für die substrategischen Waffen das ist
aber mitnichten so dass selbst eine so
große Truppe wie diese wagnertruppe die
wir da auf der Autobahn gesehen haben da
einfach hinfahren könnte eindringen da
dieses 12te hauptdirektorat der
heilungsministeriums überwältigen die
dafür zuständig sind diese Waffen zu
sichern und die in irgendeiner Weise
benutzen will jetzt nicht zu sehr ins
Detail gehen aber die Dinger sind
deaktiviert da muss man die Elektrik
sozusagen aktivieren man muss so
Neutronen Quelle einführen verschiedene
Stufen um überhaupt und dann haben die
auch noch das was man vermiss es Action
links nennt also man darf sich das nicht
vorstellen wie James Bond Film dass man
da irgendwie so eine Klappe aufschiebt
da ist der große rote Knopf dann drückt
man drauf und dann ist die scharf
sondern die Waffe selber machen
selber hat im Prinzip auch eine Sensorik
und guckt ob das überhaupt sinnvoll Käse
so sein kann dass sie jetzt detonieren
könnte und dazu muss sie zum Beispiel
öfter mal auch ein paar hundert
Kilometer geflogen sein und eine
Höhenveränderung durchlaufen haben und
so weiter also insofern ganz klar
Instabilität im nuklearstaat
Horrorvorstellung ja aber wir müssen
auch uns informieren und schauen wie
groß wir jetzt diese Gefahr am
Wochenende wirklich ich als jemand der
nun auf nuklear Themen besonders guckt
hatte da keine besonders gesteigerte
sorge dann wir sind wie bei der Frage
der interessanten Frage welche Art
eigentlich der Nachfolger von Putin
aussehen würde wenn wir nicht mehr mit
ihm am Tisch von Friedensverhandlungen
gesessen die hoffentlich bald kommen
also ich kann mir Prinz Behandlung auch
mit Putin nicht vorstellen also da noch
mal zu dem Punkt den sie gemacht haben
dieser Krieg geht unvermittelt weiter
die Vernichtung der Ukraine als Staat
und Nation ist nach wie vor das Ziel und
das wird natürlich von Putin
vorangetrieben das wird von der Elite
mitgetragen es wird von Teilen der
russischen Gesellschaft mitge insofern
bin ich auch was die russische
Entwicklung angeht sehr sehr
pessimistisch aber ich finde das ganz
wichtig was Sie gesagt haben ja sauer
vorhin dass wir darauf letztlich keinen
Einfluss haben was in Russland passiert
und irgendwann wenn es kein Palast gut
gibt wird biologisch geregelt irgendwann
stirbt Putin und da ist möglich ein
imperialer Zerfall ein gegenseitig
miteinander kämpfende Warlords sind
denkbar Tschetschenien wäre
wahrscheinlich sozusagen weg also dass
diese gewaltunternehmer dann her
vortreten miteinander konkurrieren dass
das ist denkbar ist genauso denkbar es
kommt ein Putin der nächste Putin der
zweite und der also mehr oder weniger
dasselbe Ziel verfolgt wie er das können
wir aber von außen erstmal nicht
beurteilen es war auch dieses Fehler
oder die denkt Fehler von Wolfgang
Ischinger der am Wochenende sagte wir
müssen den Zerfall Russlands aufhalten
wir können das nicht das war genau der
gleiche Denkfehler denen die Amerikaner
1991 gemacht haben als sie gedacht haben
sie können den Zerfall der Sowjetunion
aufhalten die Zerfall der Ukraine
aufhalten dass das entscheidende sich
nicht in Washington und aber wie bei
etwas anderes können wir beeinflussen
und das ist der Verlauf des Krieges
gegen die Ukraine und das ist das
anstatt uns jetzt in Spekulationen wo
wir sehr wenig Informationen haben
darüber auszulassen darauf sollten wir
uns konzentrieren wie gesagt die Morde
ich wollte dir nur diese diese These
noch mal putin ist das Gesicht genommen
worden nur um Herrn farbig auch noch mal
zu hören putin ist durch seine eigenen
Leute das Gesicht genommen worden und
der Westen muss jetzt gucken ihm diese
Gesichtswahrung zu ermöglichen damit er
eben nicht einen instabiles zerfallenes
chaotisches Russland hinterlässt und das
ist dann schon eine sehr weitgehende
Interpretation so weit sind wir ja noch
gar nicht aber im Moment bin ich nur
dagegen dass wir Wunschdenken machen und
vor David völlig recht wir haben sowieso
keinen Einfluss aber wir müssen auch
nicht Wunsch denken machen ich meine
Putin hieß es vor Monaten hat Parkinson
und hat Krebs ist schwach sozusagen kurz
vorm Ende jetzt dieser Putschversuch
oder diese Meuterei wir haben ihn
abgeschrieben ich glaube nicht daran ich
finde es gibt auch keine Anhaltspunkte
dafür putin ist der
Akteur mit dem wir sozusagen es zu tun
haben und wenn er morgen stürzt und ein
besserer kommt dann wäre ich der erste
der sich freut aber wir sollten doch
nicht auf Wunsch denken eine Strategie
bauen sondern wir müssen mit dem
Russland leben wie es im Moment ist und
wir müssen es ein hegen aber wir müssen
auch versuchen nicht in eine Eskalation
in eine weitere Eskalation mit diesem
Russland zu geraten und wir müssen vor
allen Dingen der Ukraine helfen dass sie
sich als souveräner Start behauptet dass
sie aber auch nicht ein Staat ist der
immer mehr kaputt geht und im Moment ist
die westliche Strategie nicht
erfolgreich die Ukraine geht
gewissermaßen vor die Hunde und wir tun
so als ob wir Sie unterstützen wir
meinen es vielleicht sogar gut aber
unsere Strategie geht in eine falsche
Richtung und ich bin dafür dass sie
korrigieren
diskutieren wir gleich ich wollte Katrin
Eigendorf ganz kurz noch mal fragen
die Wladimir Putin wird sich jetzt
reichen er hat prigoshi in einen
Verräter genannt und wie er mit
Verrätern sonst umgeht wissen diejenigen
die auch nur gewagt haben
mal Plakate hochzuhalten in diesem Land
was wird das Auslösen im russischen Heer
was bedeutet das für seinen Machtapparat
ich hoffe mir nicht vergessen ja ich bin
mir nicht so sicher dass Wladimir Putin
sich rächen wird weil was wir in der
Situation gesehen haben und das hat sich
auch über den Verlauf dieses Krieges
abgezeichnet da geht jemand hin eine
Söldnertruppe im Prinzip eine irreguläre
militärische Einheit deren Führer das
Regime in einer Art kritisiert hat in
der ist vorher nie so da gewesen ist
also das hat ja angefangen mit der
massiven Kritik an den Oligarchen auf
deren Reichtum das System Putin Fuß und
deren Teilchen ja selber ist
beschuldigt hat dass ihre Kinder an der
Cote d'Azur besitzen während die
normalen Russen im Krieg sterben Putin
das ist jetzt meine meine Analyse
konnte der wagnertruppe konnte pregorian
nichts entgegensetzen weil er ihn
braucht er braucht den in vielen
verschiedenen Kriegen und seinen
Einfluss der Einfluss der wagnergruppe
geht weit über die Absicherung von
afrikanischen Diktaturen von dem Assad
Regime in Syrien das reicht bis in dass
er im Prinzip die trollfabriken die in
westlichen Staaten für gegen
Desinformationskampagnen sorgen unter
anderem auch in Amerika
Erfolg haben betreibt also was ich damit
sagen will das kann Putin sich gar nicht
leisten und wir haben ja heute gibt es
ja Spekulationen auch das in St
Petersburg aufgetaucht sein soll also
erst nach Minsk und dann nach St
Petersburg aber so richtig genau
verifizieren war das nicht verifizieren
können wir es nicht es gibt verschiedene
Quellen die das behaupten und
wovon man ausgehen muss ist das
natürlich dieses Wagner Imperium auf
dessen Einfluss und macht das putinische
System basiert unter anderem
nicht einfach so jetzt zerschlagen
werden kann und es schon diese
Integration dann muss ich doch noch mal
fragen diese Integration die ab 1.7
laufen soll die pregorien ja
offensichtlich fürchtete wie der Teufel
das Weihwasser in die russische Armee
integriert zu werden in ausgerechnet
Herrn Schau Guts Armee
glauben Sie denn dass das funktionieren
wird mit denen noch wahrscheinlich 30
anderen Privatarmeen auf russischem
Territorium nein das ist ein halte ich
für sehr schwierig weil das haben wir im
Verlauf des Krieges ja gesehen was hat
den was hat denn die wagnertruppe so
stark gemacht nicht nur nicht nur in der
jetzigen Situation sondern seit vielen
Jahren die Unfähigkeit die komplette
Unfähigkeit der russischen Armee und
solche Situationen
solche Situationen aber was ich noch mal
ein interessanten Aspekt finde wenn wir
uns fragen was kommt nach Putin und was
was haben wir jetzt eigentlich gelernt
auf dieser Situation das learning Nummer
eins ist das ein schwacher Putin auch
eine Gefahr sein kann und für mich das
learning Nummer zwei ist
wo ist die liberale Opposition die
liberale Opposition hat sich in Form von
ein paar ihrer Vertreter oder kowski
casparov einer weini zwar zu Wort
gemeldet aber nicht mit mehr als mit
Analysen und Beschreibungen der
Situation aber die haben keine Strategie
die liberale
Opposition in Russland existiert
eigentlich nicht kein politisches
Konzept mit einer solchen Situation
umzugehen ja existiert eigentlich nicht
und das ist das was uns eigentlich am
meisten Sorgen machen muss für die
Zukunft Russlands es war interessant
Herr roh das ausgerechnet der grüne Ralf
höchst sagte wir müssten auch im Westen
an eine regime-change denken und das
dürfte kein Tabu mehr sein
die Frage ist mit wem würde man da
eigentlich und auf wen würde man da
eigentlich rechnen innerhalb Russlands
den man für einen solchen regime-change
natürlich bräuchte wo sind die
demokratischen die Liberalen Russen für
einen solchen sagen vielleicht helfen
sie uns erstmal bei der Beantwortung der
Frage gibt es überhaupt eine
nennenswerte
Opposition oder ist die mit einer walnie
und mit Frau duchowski entweder im Knast
in Russland oder geflohen aus Russland
eine Opposition die aus sich heraus eine
Kraft entwickeln könnte um Alternativen
zu der putinischen Diktatur auf sein
gibt es sicherlich nicht die ist
systematisch kaputtgemacht klein geredet
diskriminiert kriminalisiert worden oder
hat in herschaden das Land verlassen und
ich bin auch der Auffassung dass der das
vergangene Wochenende war nicht das Ende
von Putin aber das Ende ist ja schon
längst am 24 Februar vergangenen Jahres
eingeleitet worden denn diese mit diesem
Krieg hat sich Putin verhoben und es ist
eine Frage der Zeit wann dieses System
an dieses Regime an seine Grenzen stößt
und da bin ich wieder im Widerspruch
auch zu Herrn Warwick natürlich
ist eine ganze Menge erreicht worden
denn das Putin teilweise vor einem
Scherbenhaufen steht ist der der
Tatsache zu verdanken dass das Wunder in
der Ukraine geschehen ist dass die
Menschen mutiger waren als wir es jemals
für möglich hielten und dieser
verbrecherischen Armee standhalten
konnten und das zweite da stand ich war
dass wir geliefert haben Waffen
politische Hilfe und das muss jetzt
beschleunigt werden wir müssen jetzt
noch mehr liefern wir müssen die Ukraine
noch besser unterstützen damit sie sich
gegen diese Brutalität zu erwerben
vermag und ich halte es für möglich
putin ist schlagbar aber nur wenn wir
ihn wenn wir die ukrainische Seite
weiter unterstützen deswegen bin ich bei
allen die gesagt haben konzentrieren wir
uns doch jetzt auf das was wir ändern
können worauf wir Einfluss haben und wir
haben konkret nur auf eines Einfluss der
Ukraine zu helfen denn wenn die Ukraine
bestehen kann als souveränes freies Land
unter Wahrung ihrer territorialen
Integrität dann kann es zu Verhandlung
bekommen und das letzte noch zu
Verhandlungen und das war das für mich
Erstaunlichste an diesem historischen
Wochenende wir haben einen verängstigten
Putin erlebt so habe ich das zumindest
wahrgenommen der zum allerersten Mal den
Eindruck erweckte er sei zu
Verhandlungen bereit weil ihm
offenkundig das Wasser bis zum Hals
stand also wenn wir wirklich die Ukraine
stärker machen und mehr Druck ausüben
dann könnte das dazu führen dass auch
schon unter Putin Verhandlungen
eingeleitet werden können die er
sicherlich nicht zum Abschluss bringen
wird aber das könnte das Ende dieses
furchtbaren kriege
ich bin noch mal über etwas anderes
sprechen nämlich zu dem was Herrn wir
kommen gleich noch entschuldigung ich
wollte wir reden tatsächlich über das
was eben im eigentlichen Krieg in der
Ukraine noch geschieht ich wollte nur
fragen ob sie das auch so sehen und
heilen das absolut ja natürlich das ist
das ist eigentlich auch offensichtlich
hätte sich putinier jetzt nicht in einer
gleichen Art und Weise gemessen die mit
der Ukraine also glauben Sie dass das
gesehen dass er nur durch militärischen
Druck zu irgendwelchen auch nur
irgendwie ja nennt man es Kompromissen
aber dass das eher eben schlagbar ist
das hat man gesehen und dass er unter
Druck auch zurückweicht und die eigenen
Ankündigungen er hat er ja am Morgen
gesagt
wer dass die Verräter bestraft werden
und das hätte nicht gedacht
haben in der Situation Putin wirklich am
Tiefpunkt seiner kompletten Amtszeit
erlebt also ich habe Putin in der
gesamten Zeit in der Macht ist noch nie
in einer solchen Situationen erlebt und
ich glaube dass bei ihm selber kann ich
jetzt auch nur spekulieren die
Erkenntnis wächst dass dieser Krieg
Russland massiv schadet und auch seiner
Macht massiv schadet er muss natürlich
jetzt irgendwie einen Weg da rausfinden
und ich weiß nicht ob der darin besteht
noch mehr zu brutalisieren oder sich
Verhandlungen bereit zu erklären aber
dass sich da etwas jetzt ändert da bin
ich ziemlich überzeugt okay und damit
haben wir glaube ich einen der
wichtigsten Punkte raus repariert den
man mitnehmen sollte aus diesem
Wochenende weil das was da passiert ist
die Tatsache dass Putin noch am Morgen
im Fernsehen Standorte in einen Verräter
genannt hatte was ein Todesurteil ist
am Nachmittag sangen klanglos eingepackt
hat am nächsten Morgen die
realitätsverzerrungsmaschine angeworfen
hat allen Gedanken hat den Freiwilligen
Feuerwehren der Gewerkschaft überhaupt
der ganzen Gesellschaft die sich hinter
ihnen gestellt hätten das natürlich
alles nicht stimmt dann ordent verliehen
hat und das Thema gewechselt hat danach
ging es ja dann um Tourismus in Dagestan
zeigt das von diesem Putin der immer
herausgeschworen wurde der wenn er in
der Ecke ist dann nur noch eskaliert und
mit maximaler Gewalt reagiert ja gar
nichts übrig war wir haben ja ein ganz
anderen Putin gesehen das ist für mich
einer der wichtigsten Datenpunkte den
ich da mitnehme für die weitere Analyse
sozusagen der von dem was noch kommt
denn wenn der Druck erhöht werden kann
auf Russland dann werden wir uns ja
wieder in solchen Situationen finden wo
wir uns fragen was ist die Reaktion
und es ist entscheidend ich fand
wenigstens genauso bemerkenswert dass er
pregorien um darauf nochmal zu kommen
und das was Herr farbig sagte deshalb
pregorien ja nicht nur kritisiert hat
sehr lange kritisiert hat wie Krieg
geführt wird sondern er hat jüngst auch
ent hüllt dass er bezweifelt und völlig
in Frage stellt welche Begründung
gefunden wurde den Krieg überhaupt zu
führen dass wir uns schnell noch mal an
vor dem 24 Februar war gar nichts
Besonderes geschehen das
Verteidigungsministerium versucht die
Öffentlichkeit und den Präsidenten Irre
zu führen und er fand die Story es gebe
einen wahnwitzigen Grad an Aggression
von Seiten der Ukraine sie werde
zusammen mit dem nato-block angreifen
das ist interessant dass er das enthüllt
war das auch in ihren Augen
bemerkenswert dass er sagt es stimmt
überhaupt nicht dass die Ukraine und die
Naht also wird das was auslösen in
Russland glauben Sie also ich würde
jetzt brigoshi nicht als Kronzeugen für
irgendwas nehmen werden das
herausgearbeitet ein schlechter
sozusagen ein gewaltunternehmer und das
ist nicht glaubwürdig was er sagt
natürlich erschüttert dass äh den
putinischen Ansatz gar keine Frage
deswegen hat er ihn ja auch kaltgestellt
und dieser Ansatz ist jetzt weg und ich
glaube nicht dass Putin sich davon jetzt
bekehren lässt und die Frage wie wir
jetzt zu Verhandlungen kommen das ist
die entscheidende glaube ich und ich
glaube nicht daran dass jetzt diese
innenpolitischen Entwicklungen in
Russland zeigen dass man Putin nur in
die Ecke treiben muss und dann gibt er
was Preis sondern ich glaube dass wir in
einer militärischen Situation im Moment
sind
wo sich auf dieser 1000 km langen Freund
relativ wenig bewegt vielleicht durch
das kleinere vielleicht auch größere
Erfolge der Ukraine geben aber es wird
an dem Gesamtbild nichts ändern das
Russland gewissermaßen nicht bereit ist
sich friedlich aus dem Territorium was
es Völkerrechts Besetzer zurückzuziehen
und wenn das und viel dafür gegeben hat
das zu machen und wahrscheinlich auch
nicht zurückweichen wird und die
Möglichkeiten auch hat nicht
zurückzuweichen das heißt wenn ich die
Verhandlungssituation bewerte die
ohnehin sehr schwierig ist und das sagt
niemand dass das einfach ist und es gibt
jetzt nicht nur den Zauberstab und dann
kann man verhandeln sondern man das ist
ganz schwierig alles aber das kann nur
dann gelingen wenn über Kompromisse
geredet wird und diese ukrainische
friedensformel die jetzt in aller Munde
ist die besagt im Prinzip das Russland
seine Niederlage anerkennen soll und das
einzige worüber man verhandeln kann mit
den Russen ist die Zelle in Den Haag ob
sie groß oder klein ist und Putin und
das ist
und sie haben auch das nächsten
jahrmarktpapier und gehen davon aus dass
diese Gespräche in Kopenhagen das haben
sie aber verfolgt das heißt es gibt also
Herr Warwick auch nicht an entweder oder
also Krieg oder oder Verhandlungen
sondern wir wissen ja jetzt alle längst
eine eindimensionale Strategie die auf
Waffenlieferung setzt und auf die
Annahme setzt dass die Ukraine damit
Erfolg haben würde und ich glaube das
wird nicht funktionieren ich glaube wir
brauchen wirklich politische Energie in
Verhandlungen wir müssen jetzt ein
politisches Endspiel beginnt
und das passiert zu wenig es gibt zum
Beispiel bis heute kein amerikanischen
Sonderbeauftragter für Verhandlungen es
gibt das Rammstein Format wo die
militärische Hilfe sehr gut und intensiv
koordiniert wird aber da ist ein
Ungleichgewicht zu der politischen
Bemühungen um einen Interessenausgleich
mit Russland und ohne einen
Interessenausgleich wird es nicht gehen
es wird auch der Ukraine nicht helfen
dass wir das so weitermachen wie wir es
wissen warum hat nun selbst immer nur
gesagt dass wir russische
Sicherheitsinteressen berücksichtigen
müssen jetzt verdreht vor
und hilft uns mit einem ersten Schritt
also zu diesem russischen
Sicherheitsinteressen die haben ja die
haben ja sozusagen die ganze
fehlgeleitete Russlandpolitik seit 2014
bestimmt weil diese sogenannten Russland
russischen Sicherheitsinteressen immer
Neo imperiale Ansprüche auf die Ukraine
waren und ich finde es wirklich
bemerkenswerter Warwick das ausgerechnet
wie der sie sich als Realist bezeichnen
nicht bereit sind die Realität zur
Kenntnis zu nehmen und sie auch
angemessen begrifflich zu fassen
Kompromisslösungen ja Verhandlungen ja
politischer Lösung das hört sich alles
schön an das sind die Formeln die sie
wiederholen nachdem das was sie
eigentlich gesagt hatten am 25 Februar
das Kiew in drei Tagen fallen wird und
wir ein Exil Regierungen der Ukraine in
Warschau oder Berlin brauchen nachdem
das nicht eingetreten ist aber sie gibt
sie sie füllen diese Begriffe nie mit
leben weil es darum mich auch nicht geht
und sie sie sagen jetzt die Ukraine hat
eine zu er geht mit einer zu hohen
Erwartung in irgendwelche Verhandlungen
es ist doch russ die Vernichtungsabsicht
hat wo ist das natürlich überhaupt gar
nicht nur ich bin an einer Lösung
interessiert ja nein aber ja aber die
soll das aussehen wie machen ich habe
gerade gesagt es gibt keinen Zauberstab
aber ich glaube wir müssen mit einem
mindset daran gehen dass wir sozusagen
die territoriale Frage nicht tabuisieren
und dass wir auch die Frage der
Zugehörigkeit der Entschuldigung wenn
wenn wir Fragen
diese territoriale Veränderung
akzeptieren ich glaube nicht daran dass
die krimen wieder Ukraine wird und ich
glaube nicht dass es ein realistisches
Ziel ist das auch nicht sie war
eigentlich nicht sie das ist doch gar
nicht der Punkt ich will doch rausführen
was was weiter Elemente
sie haben gefragt so der erste Punkt ist
dass man über diese territoriale Frage
neu nachdenken muss und der zweite Punkt
ist dass man diese
Selbstverständlichkeit mit der man
annimmt dass die Ukraine komplett im
westlichen Lager landet in der NATO
eines Tages und in der Europäischen
Union dass man das in Frage stellt dass
man also über einen anderen Status der
Ukraine nachdenkt und die verdrehen die
Augen das sind alles Unangenehme
unappetitliche Realitäten die aber nur
zu ändern wären wenn Russland wenn
Russland darf ich diesen Satz noch sagen
die nur zu ändern wären wenn Russland
eine komplette Niederlage erleidet die
ich mir wünschen würde die ich aber für
unrealistisch halten und das ist der
Punkt
auf den ich jetzt doch mal eingehen will
ja sie sagen territoriale Fragen ja man
soll das nicht tabuisieren sprechen Sie
doch bitte wenigstens aus was das für
die Menschen denen sie das empfehlen
bedeutet ein verbrecherisches gehen
ein Element einer Lösung sein das ist
auch für die Menschen von Vorteil
möglicherweise auch wenn sie nicht dafür
sind das gebe ich gerne zu uns ist
wirklich also entschuldigen Sie aber das
geht an der Realität so derart vorbei
wir haben doch wir haben doch die
Berichte wir haben easium wir haben
alpin ja wir haben Gutschein erlebt ja
die Menschen werden was sie jetzt
territoriale Fragen nennen ist in der
Realität und diese Realität sollten so
viel Respekt sollten Sie doch vor den
Ukrainern haben dass wenn sie ihnen
schon aus dem sicheren Deutschland
solche Ratschläge erteilen dass sie so
mindest die Würde der Opfer insofern
respektieren dass sie die Realität
aussprechen das ist nämlich ein genauso
wie geht es genauso um die Opfer
ganz wichtiger Punkt unter Besatzung
unter russischer Besatzung und das wäre
eine russische Übersetzung wird weiter
gestorben aber lassen Sie uns den Blick
doch mal weiten wir verhaken uns jetzt
glaube ich sehr an der Frage der Ukraine
Russland bedroht nicht nur die Ukraine
sondern die Ukraine ist im Prinzip ein
stellvertreterfeld Russland bedroht im
Prinzip eine internationale
sicherheitsordnung zu der sich große
Teile der Welt nach dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg verständigt haben Russland
bedroht auch Deutschland ich weiß nicht
ob sie so argumentieren würden wenn es
um die Frage ginge ob wir Teile
Deutschlands abtreten also die russische
Regierung das Putin Regime hat Europa
hat der freien Welt den Krieg erklärt
und führt diesen Krieg aktiv in der
Ukraine aber für diesen Krieg auf
Informationsbasis schon lange gegen den
Westen und ich denke er hat auf die
Bereitschaft das auf militärische Angeln
das müssen wir doch einfach
einkalkulieren
also ich finde erstmal
es legitim erfahrwik gibt vielen
Menschen eine Stimme die sich auch an
mich wenden Frieden Verhandlung aber ich
finde dass wir so ehrlich sein müssten
um die Konsequenzen aufzuzeigen den
einen wichtigen Punkt hat Frau Eigendorf
gesagt es geht nicht alleine um die
Ukraine wenn Putin jetzt nicht in der
Ukraine mit seinem imperialistischen und
kolonialistischen Anspruch gestoppt wird
dann wird es im Osten Europas weitere
militärische Konflikte geben Georgien
Moldau andere also wir werden diesen
Krieg nicht stoppen können indem wir
jetzt etwas von der Ukraine verlangen
was in der konsequenten Linie der
europäischen bisweilen auch deutschen
auch amerikanischen
Russlandpolitik der vergangenen
Jahrzehnte lag nämlich den Osten Europas
der als den Hinterhof Putins zu
betrachten indem man sich nicht Grenze
mischen hat wir mischen uns doch gar
nicht einer Fahrweg diese Menschen die
wollen so leben wie wir die wollen
Freiheit Demokratie Rechtsstaatlichkeit
und die Ukraine ist ein souveränes Land
und das was sie tun ist permanent die
Souveränität die Integrität eines Landes
in Frage zu stellen und ein allerletztes
wir führen über alles öffentliche
Debatten wie viel Waffen wir liefern was
für Waffen wir liefern aber wenn wir
über Frieden reden dann hat das ein
Höchstmaß von von diskretionen
Vertraulichkeit zur Folge und da sie ja
manche als
gesinnungsfundamentalisten bezeichnen
herfahrweg sehe ich mich als
Verantwortungsethiker weil ich nämlich
weiß wenn wir öffentlich so wie sie das
tun über mögliche Kompromisslinien
sprechen die der Ukraine etwas
abverlangen nämlich möglicherweise auf
20% ihres Territoriums zu verzichten
dann stärken wir automatisch die
Position des aggress aus Russland und
automatisch die Position der Ukraine und
damit wird die Ukraine immer kleiner und
ich finde das ist unsere Aufgabe ist als
Verbündeter als Partner auch als
Freundinnen und Freunde des Friedens
eben Russland kleiner zu halten und der
Ukrainer ein Überlebenschance
einzuräumen vor dave ist noch ganz kurz
dann müssen wir Ben Hodges unbedingt
noch mal nach den letzten Nachrichten
Fragen einfach nur noch mal darauf
hinweisen historisch sozusagen also
zeitgeschichtlich diese Strategie wenn
man sie so nennen will ich das war
eigentlich eine Überforderung eine
Unfähigkeit der Realität ins Auge zu
sehen die hatten wir schon seit 2014 bis
2022 im Grunde genommen hat sich da
nicht viel getan ja die Krim wurde im
Grunde genommen zwar nicht offiziell
anerkannt aber es war auch die Weigerung
die Ukraine wirklich militärisch zu
stärken und trotzdem ist dieser Krieg
oskaliert weil Putin das wollte ja und
ich finde es auch sehr zynisch zu sagen
diese diese Strategie die der besten
jetzt fährt nämlich endlich die
politische Entscheidung zu treffen die
Ukraine militärisch zu zerstört
unterstützen dass das keine Erfolge
erzielt erzählen sie das auch den den
Menschen die befreit worden sind von dem
russischen
Besatzungsregime die sich gefreut haben
dass sie wieder in ihrem eigenen Land
frei leben können ich finde das wirklich
zynisch somit den Erfahrungen dieser
Menschen umzugehen und noch ein weil wir
hier wieder mal die Ukraine ohne
ukrainische Stimmen diskutieren wichtig
nur mal
ukrainischen intellektuellen gut
zitieren der eben sagt ich nehme niemand
übel dass er Angst hat vor Putin und
sagt ich hoffe wenn wir ihm irgendwie
ein Stück Ukraine geben dann ist er ja
vielleicht ruhig und lässt uns in Ruhe
ich verstehe Angst was ich nicht
akzeptieren kann und er ist wirklich ein
Deutschland Kenner er kennt die Leute
die Debatte gut was ich nicht
akzeptieren kann an einer Position so
wie sie sie her verwahrweg formulieren
das so getan wird als hätten diese Leute
eine Lösung die in den Interesse der
Ukraine wäre und das ist das in Farmern
eine kleine Zusatz Bemerkung ich würde
sogar so weit gehen dass unsere Konzepte
unsere Frieden sogenannten
friedenskonzepte von 2014 sogar
zu dem Krieg wie wir ihn heute erleben
geführt haben also ohne das ist eine
andere Frage ich behaupte nur und ich
glaube das kann man an den letzten
Monaten sehen dass es am Ende nur die
Frage ist wann wir verhandeln und die
Frage ist wie viel Opfern nehmen wir
noch in Kauf bis Verhandlungen ernsthaft
betrieben werden und hier und wir dürfen
nicht immer weiter in dieser
eskalationslogisch reden sondern müssen
Einsatz noch Verhandlungen auch
präventive eskalationskontrolle sehen
weil wir haben uns ein bisschen daran
gewöhnt dass diese Dinge sozusagen jetzt
in einer patzsituation ändern das ist
aber keine Garantie dieser Krieg kann
auch jederzeit noch stärker eskalieren
als jetzt schon das heißt wir müssen
verhandeln um Eskalation zu vermeiden es
gibt ähm Herr Sauer in der New York
Times einen Bericht darüber dass auch
offiziell die offen das offizielle
Washington die Ukraine gegen Offensive
als ernüchternd betrachtet wenn man sich
anschaut wie wenig da eigentlich
geschafft wurde ist das nicht ein
Argument
das tatsächlich Herrn
unterstreicht und unterstützt es ist
wahnsinnig schwer und ist sterben
wahnsinnig viele Menschen
Einsatz vorab also das was er war weg
jetzt so etwas verklausuliert
beschrieben hat hat er ja letztes Jahr
immer noch finden dannisierung genannt
so ein Finnland ist
ja aus guten Gründen warum weil sie
Angst vor Putins Angriffs kriegen haben
also das sozusagen nur mal nebenbei und
ja ansonsten muss ich sagen es stimmt
die nach eigener Aussage aus der
ukrainischen Perspektive
ist diese Gegenoffensive bisher unter
den Erwartungen geblieben ich würde
sagen es gibt immer noch drei Punkte die
für die Ukraine sprechen sie haben das
bessere gerät sie haben die kürzeren
Wege ja Russland muss längere Wege an
der Front zurücklegen
und sie haben natürlich die bessere
Kamera die verteidigen und befreien
Irland aber es spricht dagegen Herr rot
hat es angesprochen sie haben zu wenig
von dem besseren Gerät insbesondere mit
Blick auf die Boden gebundene Luft
Verteidigung deswegen können diese ka 52
diese Kampf Helikopter
diese Kolonnen angreifen wo wir dann die
Bilder sehen Bradleys Leos und so weiter
das schwierig sie müssen oft offen ist
durchqueren was brutal ist und darüber
haben wir auch schon sehr sehr viel
gesprochen natürlich Zeit eine
Verteidigung vorzubereiten
wassersperren und so weiter aber das
unseriöse ist dass Herr Warwick der nun
wirklich ein sehr schlechten track
record hat ihn hat alles überrascht
fragilson er hat mit nichts gerechnet
sich hier hinsetzt
sie haben gerade hier gesessen
und die wird so bleiben und ich sage
Ihnen ganz offen wissenschaftlich wir
wissen es nicht wenn wir in drei Monaten
noch mal zusammen kommen dann glaube ich
können wir in den vernünftige
Beurteilung Fällen darüber wie das läuft
jetzt sind zwei bis drei Wochen und
solche militärischen Kampagnen dauern in
der Regel drei Monate deswegen finde ich
es nochmal unseriös wenn Sie hier sitzen
und sagen Sie wissen schon wie das
ausgeht wir wissen es nicht es kann sein
dass sie Recht haben dass wir in drei
Monaten tatsächlich immer noch ein paar
haben es kann auch anders sein und so
sollte man auf die Dinge gucken und so
analysiert man das aus meiner Sicht
vernünftig aber sie sagen
den Realitäten orientiert nehmen wir
ganz kurz mit und sind noch mal bei wenn
hojus in Frankfurt wenn auch an Sie die
Frage nach der Einschätzung aus der
US-Administration dass die Situation
bisher am Boden er nüchternd läuft und
offensichtlich auch Präsident selensky
unzufrieden ist mit dem was ich bisher
erreichen ließ
möchte ich sagen das ist natürlich
wichtig ist maybrit darauf hinzuweisen
dass was wir von den russischen
Streitkräften in der vergangenen Woche
auch gesehen haben diesen Aufstand und
auch die Frage zur russischen
Führungskräften und auf welcher Seite
sie sich befinden das ist nicht etwas
was in einer Armee passiert die wirklich
am selbstbewusst sagt wir sind auf dem
Weg zum Sieg die Ukrainer können sehen
dass die russische Führung sehr schwach
ist dass die Soldaten anfangen an sich
selbst zu zweifeln und was wir erleben
werden und zwar schon bald ist das die
Ukraine in der Lage sein werden genau
daraus einen Nutzen zu ziehen es gab
sehr viele defizistische pessimistische
Sprache und Formulierung die aus dem
Washington gekommen sind von sogenannten
Experten zu dem was da passiert ist und
ich glaube dass das komplette Unsinn ist
dass die kommt er diese diese gegen
Offensive die jetzt eben erstmal seit
drei Wochen unterwegs ist und was wir
gerade gehört haben stimmt einfach es
wird mehr als drei Monate dauern um zu
sehen was die Ukraine schafft und das
ist nämlich die unvermeidliche
Penetration das Durchbrechen durch die
russischen Verteidigungslinie es gibt
also an Panzersperren Minen das sind
also natürlich verteilungsmechanismen
aber das Wichtigste sind Soldaten und
ich schaue mir an was da in den Gräben
zu sehen ist und was die Führungskräfte
dort machen und ich glaube nicht dass
sie besonders enthusiastisch sein werden
wenn es darum geht weiter zu kämpfen
wenn die Ukraine mehr und mehr Druck
aufbauen und dann haben wir heute auch
noch Berichte darüber gehört dass es den
anscheinend hat dass die beiden
Regierung jetzt endlich sie gerade
ernsthaft ernsthaft darüber nachdenkt
Ihnen auch die
Langstrecken an die Ukraine
weiterzugeben das wird ein ganz
Unterschied machen denn die werden dafür
sorgen dass die Krim für die russischen
Luft und auch Seestreitkräfte unhaltbar
wird und das wird auch die ukrainische
Streitkräfte dann in die Lage
logistische Stützpunkte der Russen
anzugreifen
und wenn das passiert dann sollte
natürlich Deutschland auch Tausch zur
Verfügung stellen sollte Deutschland
auch Taurus zur Verfügung stellen die
reichen dann 400 Kilometer weit ich
wollte nur noch mal sagen dass das heute
das Wort Street Journal meldete dass die
US-Administration dazu bereit wäre
dieser weiterreichenden
Kurzstreckenraketen zur Verfügung zu
stellen und dennoch muss man sagen wenn
heute ist wenn es in diesem Tempo weiter
ginge der Herbst ist bald
sagen wollen dass die US-Regierung jetzt
schon sehr viele vorbereitende Arbeiten
geleistet hat um zu dieser Entscheidung
zu kommen ich weiß nicht wie es das dann
aussehen wird natürlich
ist es immer noch schwierig es ist
glaube ich eine falsche Aussage der
Regierung gewesen zu sagen wir haben
nicht genügend Systeme die wir zur
Verfügung stellen können und
gleichzeitig exportieren die Hersteller
das aber nach Polen und den anderen
Länder das ist also eine Frage des
politischen Willens und nicht so sehr
der Verfügbarkeit deswegen glaube ich
wenn wir es ernst meinen dann und die
beiden Regierung auch sagt wir möchten
dass die Ukraine gewinnt und das liegt
am besten Interesse aller Länder im
Westen dass die Ukraine erfolgreich ist
dann wird das auch so geschehen
vielen Dank nach Frankfurt an dieser
Stelle wie viel Hoffnung wollte ich
Kathrin Eigendorf noch Fragen mit wie
viel Hoffnung schauen Sie nach
Kopenhagen ist das ein nennenswerter ein
bemerken Leute friedensversuch ich Simon
ich sehe im Moment die Perspektiven die
kurzfristigen Perspektiven für die
Ukraine sehr kritisch weil ich glaube
was wir nicht vergessen dürfen russland
hat noch Eskalationspotenzial
Eskalationspotenzial zum Beispiel ein
Atomkraftwerk in die Luft zu jagen das
müssen ja nicht muss ja nicht der
Einsatz von taktischen Atomwaffen sein
dass er diese Minen nicht entdecken
konnte in dem Kühlbecken aber trotzdem
nukleare Katastrophe über die reden wir
nun schon seit Monaten das sehe ich im
Moment als ein großes Bedrohungsszenario
und es gibt noch viele andere Ebenen auf
der Russland in diesem Krieg ein
eskalieren kann und wir haben gesehen
die Ukraine haben und selenski das ja
auch sehr skeptisch gesehen die
Situation hat jetzt nicht direkt
Momentum daraus gewinnen können aus
dieser Situation also heute wurde
kremators
bombardiert ja solche
praktisch ja katastrophalen Situation
kann Russland relativ leicht
herbeiführen mit sehr sehr schweren
Verlusten für die Ukraine weil sie
einfach weil die Ukraine keine
vernünftige Luft Verteidigung haben also
ich
glaube dass Momentum dass wenn die
Ukraine es kriegen kann und davon bin
ich langfristig überzeugt dass sie es
bekommen wird wird sich noch über viele
Monate ziehen und sehr sehr davon
abhängig sein wie weit der Westen denn
wirklich bereit ist beherzt dort mit
Waffen entsprechend zu unterstützen
machen wir hier einen Punkt darf mich
ganz herzlich bei allen Gästen der
Sendung bedanken und gebe auch natürlich
nach Frankfurt noch mal zu bernhardis
und gebe sie mit diese Frage einer
schwer zu beantwortenden Frage ob wir
eher eine Chance oder tatsächlich
irgendwie eher einer Niederlage
entgegensehen zu Markus Lanz der heute
unter anderem Bettina stark Bötzinger zu
Gast hat und wir sehen uns wenn Sie
mögen kommen Donnerstag wieder 22:15 Uhr
gleiche Stelle gleiche Wetter bis dahin
tschüss vielen Dank
[Musik]